hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over a trap in the
italian game it's the chagoran trap and
this was played from an actual game from
shigorn and so that's how it got the
name but the italian
game is one of the most popular openings
in all chess starts out with e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop to c4 and
then we're going to be looking at the
gioco piano with bishop c5 now white has
lots of ways to respond but decides to
go ahead and play the castle on at the
king sideline knight to f6 and then
after d3
d6 this is where we start getting into
the trap
white plays bishop g5
and then black pushes forward with h6
forcing the bishop to come back many
times if you play bishop g5 pinning down
the knights you want to maintain
pressure with your bishop and you bring
your bishop back to h4 now you're okay
if your opponent plays g5 because
although you can no longer maintain the
pressure on this pin
your opponent has now extended the pawns
farther than they would want to on the
king side of the board so bishop comes
back g3 and this is where we lay our
trap we play the move pawn h5 and it
looks pretty weird because the pawn on
g5 no longer has protection and even
from white standpoint if they think
there's some trap well okay the the
queen isn't really involved into the
game and it can get involved into the
game because it's gonna have to move
past this knight on f6
it can't come up to d7 or get involved
without a few moves here and so from
white's standpoint they can take on g5
and have the immediate threat of white
takes on f7
attacking both the rook and the queen
being protected by the bishop it seems
very difficult for black to have a
threat but that's exactly
the trap we are going to lay on our
opponent and that's the same trap that
shogorn laid when he played this trap as
black play continues with pawn to h4 and
you can start to see the threat that
black has attacking the bishop the
bishop cannot move anywhere it is now
completely trapped but that's not the
only threat that black has in store
now because the bishop is completely
lost
it essentially is coming down to how can
white now
maximize the amount of material they're
going to get and the right move for
white is to play knight takes on f7 yes
they could also take with the bishop on
f7
but this just isn't as ideal because
king 2 e7 and then you're just going to
see some exchanges yes remember the pawn
is attacking the bishop so the bishop
can decide let's just go and start
taking material off the board knight
takes on e5 maybe d4 opening up the
center uh now attacking both these minor
pieces can just take that bishop off on
f7 and after some of the exchanges here
uh you you can see that
yes the king is exposed here on f7
but the queen on d1 although it starts
to attack it's going to be difficult to
attack all alone and with none of the
bishops on the side for white
black's in a pretty good spot here so if
we come back instead of the bishop
taking on f7 it makes a lot more sense
to go ahead and continue with the same
game plan of knight 2 f7 and now they're
attacking the queen
on d8 and also the rook on h8 which is
currently protecting the pawn on h4
and you can start to see what black is
thinking about because the queen on d8
remember when you're playing these traps
it's not about how much material you
have on the board it's what material you
have involved in the attack so we can
see and we already pointed out the queen
on d8 is not really involved and it's
going to take a few moves to get
involved so we don't really care about
it we're going to sacrifice that queen
we're first going to take with our pawn
on g3 and take that bishop
so white's going to continue take the
queen on d8 and now we're going to play
bishop g4 now we're attacking the queen
you can see we also have the threat of
the bishop on c5 that's pinning down
this pawn so the pawn just can't take
here on g3 that would be an illegal move
and so we start to have a lot of threats
here now the the queen's gonna be forced
to move here because since the
the pawn can't move no longer has the
knight to block it and the bishop
can't come over here because it's
blocked by its own pawn chain here so
queen to d2 makes a lot of sense you
still want to maintain pressure on the
f2 square since black is attacking it
and something like e1 this now blocks
off the rook from ever coming uh to e1
d1 or
c1 so probably the best move is just to
play
queen to
d2
but from here black plays knight d4 and
it has a lot of threats one of the
threats is to play the move
knight to e2 this is check and so you
know attacking the the king here is one
of the immediate threats in the
particular game and we're going to come
back to a few situations and see how
white could have responded differently
but one of the threats that we're
looking at
is the night coming to e2 and so in the
actual game that shkorn played
white played the move knight to c3 and
said i see this knight to e2 move and so
i'm gonna stop that with my knight on c3
the problem is this is actually just
losing for
white
and this shows the power of the trap
it's really difficult to see all the
threats until it plays out because black
has the move knights f3 we already
talked about that the pawn can't take on
a g3 and points being pinned down now
this is check if the king just comes to
h1 we can see that's going to be
checkmate with our rook on h2 so that is
not an option the only other option is
to take the knight on f3 but once white
does that black can take with the bishop
on f3 and there's no way to really stop
the mating pattern let's say they take
with the pawn on
uh g3 okay we'll now just rook to h1
that is going to be checkmate
if they
don't move uh that the pawn to g3 maybe
they try to stop it uh they just play
pawn to h3
okay well now we're just going to play
rook to h3
that's not going to work as well maybe
they decide to go ahead and
free up their king so they move their
rook to
c1 and now we play pawn takes on h2
king 2f1 and now queen h1
so you can see that white really doesn't
have a
spot to move in black's next move is
just to threaten with pawn takes on h2
and this is also going to be checkmate
the pawn is protected by the rook and
the square here on h1 and g2 are both
protected by the bishop on f3 so you can
see there's just no way around it in the
actual game uh white did take here on g3
and then rook h1 this was checkmate so
if we come back we can see that knight
to c3 is not going to stop the threat
now what if white plays
h3 okay well this makes some sense uh
but from here black can play the move
knight to e to check
now let's look at a few options of what
this would
end up if they look at and say okay that
the king needs to move it can't come to
h2 if it comes to h2 or excuse me h1
this is going to end up in checkmate
rook takes on h3 the pawn takes and now
bishop f3
this is checkmate the only option that
white has
is to actually take the queen
remember black gave up the queen on d8
so it's not terrible for white to give
back their queen but this is just losing
for white the bishop takes on e2
and potentially now they play knight to
e6
they would do this because they re
recognized that okay now it comes down
to there's no mating threats going on
anymore and so how can they maintain as
much of their material as possible their
knight is under attack their rook is
also under attack on f1 so they have to
keep that in mind but the knight here on
e6
does want to make sure that they don't
just lose this and it's also attacking
the bishop on c5 best move for black is
to play bishop to b6 the reason for that
is black really wants to maintain this
pressure on this long dark diagonal
because we want to give white more
opportunities
to make a mistake one of those mistakes
if they look at and say okay my knight
is safe now
but now if i look at my rook
i need to move that rook
and so if they play rook to e1 this
would be a massive mistake because yes
the rook's not going to be taken by the
bishop but now they're just going to end
up losing the game starting with pawn
takes on f2 check
you can see if the king comes to h1 then
just the pawn takes on
uh e1 gets a queen and this is going to
be uh checkmate the pawn can't take it's
being pinned down by the rook if instead
the king doesn't come to h1
now maybe we have king to h2 okay well
it's going to be same thing
knight to g4 check
maybe even king 2 g3 but then we can
take on e1 we can promote to a queen or
a bishop i think it's funnier if we take
with our pawn and promote to a bishop
just because this is a pretty
interesting way to checkmate but all in
all it does not matter
if they decide
hey i want to hold on to this rook and
move that rook they are going to lose so
if we look at this after bishop to b6
later we can take their rook on f1 we're
going to get some of that material back
if you look at and say well lights up a
couple
points from the pawn standpoint yes we
are now going to take their rook we can
also take their pawn put pressure on uh
this f2 square since we are protected
with our bishop so definitely going to
be
an interesting in game but but i think
black has the advantage in this spot so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this trap
always fun to see these older games with
some of the top players they were very
creative in their traps and how that can
apply uh and we can start to see all the
threats that they were looking at and
one of the most popular openings in the
italian game so thank you so much for
watching hopefully you enjoyed it if you
have other ideas on videos let me know
in the comments below but i'll see you
guys in the next video